(APPLAUSE)
WELL, THE LATEST TREND INVOLVING
MILLENNIALS OVERSHARING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA IS HERE:
"AFTER SEX SELFIES."
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
THEY ARE EXACTLY WHAT THEY
SOUND LIKE: COUPLES POSTING
PICTURES IN INSTAGRAM WITH
HASHTAG "#AFTERSEX,"
WHICH I ASSUME IS THE MOMENT
RIGHT AFTER THEY HAVE SEX.
THAT IS ALSO A SHOW
THAT I WOULD HOST.
AN AFTER SEX SHOW.
(APPLAUSE)
I AM GOING TO SHOW YOU AN
AFTER SEX SELFIE OF A POST
COITAL COUPLE AND I WANT YOU TO
GIVE ME THEIR INNER MONOLOGUE.
LET'S START WITH THIS TATTOOED
COUPLE, THEY JUST DID IT.
(LAUGHTER)
ESTHER.
>> "NOW WE CAN GO BACK TO BEING
THE CLASSIEST COUPLE IN TAMPA."
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
>> "WE GOT THESE TATS WHILE
(BLEEP)ING."
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: OKAY, NEXT ONE.
THESE TWO, HOW ABOUT THESE TWO?
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
>> Chris: WELL, THAT SEEMED
TO GO WELL.
DOUG.
>> "REGRET HAS MANY FACES."
>> Chris: POINTS, POINTS.
(APPLAUSE)
GREG, YOU HAD ONE?
>> YEAH, I'D LIKE, UH...
IS HE GOING TO LEAVE HIS FIST
IN THERE?
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
(CHEERING)
I'M A RELATIONSHIP EXPERT.
IT'S OKAY, I CAN SAY THAT.
>> Chris: GREG, SO YOU'RE SAYING
HE IS JUST THAT INTO HER.
>> ALL THE WAY.
ALL THE WAY.
>> Chris: WELL DONE, POINTS.
ALL RIGHT, LAST ONE, LAST ONE,
THIS GUY FLYING SOLO HERE.
(LAUGHTER)
DOUG.
>> "LOOK MA, NO WIFE!"
>> Chris: POINTS.
ANYONE ELSE?
ESTHER.
>> "25 YEARS TOGETHER
AND WE'VE NEVER FOUGHT ONCE."
>> Chris: POINTS.